MISSION TO CONDUCT A
RADIOLOGICAL ASSESSMENT OF
CHERNOBYL SOON.
>>> TO FRANCE NOW, AND THIS
YEAR'S RACE FOR THE ELYSEES
LOOKS LIKE DEJA VU.
VOTERS NARROWED DOWN THEIR
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES AND THE
FINALISTS ARE INCUMBENT
PRESIDENT EMMANUEL MACRON AND
HIS FAR-RIGHT RIVAL MARINE LE
PEN.
FRANCE'S INTERIOR MINISTRY
REPORTS THAT THE CURRENT
PRESIDENT WON ABOUT 27% OF
SUNDAY'S FIRST ROUND OF VOTING,
PUTTING HIM IN FIRST PLACE IN A
CROWDED FIELD OF A DOZEN
CANDIDATES.
LE PEN IS IN SECOND PLACE WITH
AROUND 23%.
THE SECOND ROUND OF VOTING IN
TWO WEEKS IS SET TO BE A REMATCH
OF THE 2017 ELECTION.
AFTER THE POLLS CLOSE, THE
CENTRIST MACRON MADE HIS PITCH,
WHILE THE FAR-RIGHT LE PEN MADE
APPEALS TO THE MAINSTREAM.
>> Translator: I WANT A FRANCE
WHICH ENSCRIBES ITSELF IN A
STRONG EUROPE, WHICH CONTINUES
TO FORM ALLIANCES WITH GREAT
DEMOCRACIES TO DEFEND ITSELF.
NOT A FRANCE THAT EXITED FROM
EUROPE WOULD HAVE FOR ITS ONLY
ALLIES THE INTERNATIONAL
POPULACE AND XENOPHOBES.
THAT'S NOT US.
>> Translator: THE FRENCH PEOPLE
HAVE SPOKEN AND GAVE ME THE
HONOR TO BE QUALIFIED IN THE
SECOND ROUND AGAINST THE
INCUMBENT PRESIDENT EMMANUEL
MACRON.
LET ME EXPRESS TO THE MILLIONS
OF VOTERS WHO EXPRESSED THEIR
TRUST IN ME MY SINCEREST
GRATITUDE.
I ACKNOWLEDGE IN HUMILITY ALL
THE RESPONSIBILITY THAT COMES
WITH IT.
>> THIS YEAR'S ELECTION SAW
SIGNIFICANT ABSTENTIONS WITH
VOTER PARTICIPATION FALLING TO A
TWO-DECADE LOW FOR A FIRST-ROUND
VOTE.
AS CNN'S PAULA NEWTON REPORTS,
THE QUESTION NOW IS WHEN THE
CANDIDATES CAN INSPIRE NONVOTERS
TO SHOW UP FOR THE SECOND, FINAL
ROUND.
>> Reporter: SUNDAY IN PARIS.
FOR MANY FRENCH PEOPLE, IT WAS A
LAISSEZ FAIRE KIND OF DAY.
TO LOUNGE BY THE SEINE OR ENJOY
A DRINK AT A CAFE.
THERE WAS ONE ACTIVITY MANY
PEOPLE AROUND THE COUNTRY
DECIDED TO SKIP, VOTING IN THE
FIRST ROUND OF THE COUNTRY'S
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTIONS.
THE CANDIDATES VOTED.
BUT TURNOUT FOR THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY WAS LESS IMPRESSIVE.
A FRENCH POLLING GROUP ESTIMATES
LESS THAN 75% OF VOTERS CAST
THEIR BALLOTS, WHICH WOULD BE
THE LOWEST TURNOUT FOR A
FIRST-ROUND VOTE IN 20 YEARS.
SOME VOTERS SAY THEY JUST
COULDN'T RELATE TO ANY OF THE
CANDIDATES OR THEIR POLICIES.
>> Translator: NO ONE REPRESENTS
ME.
I THINK THEY ARE DISCONNECTED,
AND I THINK FRANCE IS TIRED OF
THIS.
>> Reporter: FOR THOSE WHO DID
VOTE, SOME SAY IT BOILED DOWN TO
A CHOICE BETWEEN CONSISTENCY AND
CHANGE.
THIS WOMAN SAYS SHE VOTED FOR
INCUMBENT PRESIDENT EMMANUEL
MACRON.
>> Translator: I'M RELATIVELY
SATISFIED WITH WHAT HE'S DONE UP
TO NOW.
WE'RE NEVER 100% HAPPY, BUT I
THINK HE'S DONE A LOT OF GOOD
THINGS.
>> Reporter: MACRON'S
HIGH-PROFILE ROLE AS A MEDIATOR
BETWEEN RUSSIA AND UKRAINE WAS A
PLUS FOR SOME OF HIS SUPPORTERS.
>> WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE
SOMEBODY WHO IS WELL POSITIONED
IN THE INTERNATIONAL LANDSCAPE,
THE INTERNATIONAL DISCUSSIONS.
>> Reporter: BUT THIS WOMAN SAYS
SHE WASN'T SATISFIED WITH HOW
THE GOVERNMENT HANDLED THE
COVID-19 PANDEMIC.
>> Translator: IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO VOTE BECAUSE
WE WANT CHANGE.
I WANT CHANGE BECAUSE IT HAS
BEEN TWO VERY DIFFICULT YEARS.
>> Reporter: OTHER ISSUES LIKE
IMMIGRATION AND IDENTITY WERE
MAJOR PLATFORMS FOR FAR-RIGHT
CANDIDATES LIKE MARINE LE PEN
AND HIT HOME WITH SOME VOTERS.
>> Translator: WITH ALL THESE
IMMIGRANTS WHO COME, FRANCE IS
NOW NO LONGER US, IT'S THEM.
>> Reporter: OTHERS SAY IT
WASN'T SO MUCH THE ISSUES THAT
BROUGHT THEM OUT AS MUCH AS IT
WAS THEIR DUTY.
>> Translator: BECAUSE THERE'S
TOO MUCH PEOPLE THAT FOUGHT FOR
US TO HAVE THE RIGHT TO VOTE, SO
WHAT DOES IT TAKE TO WAKE UP A
LITTLE EARLIER TO VOTE ON TIME
AND EXPRESS ONE'S OPINION?
>> Reporter: EXIT POLLS SHOW
MACRON AND LE PEN WILL HEAD TO
THE SECOND ROUND OF VOTING IN
TWO WEEKS.
TO HAVE A SHOT AT VICTORY, BOTH
WILL NEED TO CONVINCE THE PEOPLE
WHO DIDN'T SHOW UP SUNDAY TO NOT
ONLY VOTE ON APRIL 24th, BUT TO
VOTE FOR THEM.
>>> I'D LIKE TO BRING IN ST
STEVENER LINGER, CHIEF
DIPLOMATIC CORRESPONDENT FOR THE
"NEW YORK TIMES" AND JOINS US
LIVE FROM BRUSSELS, BELGIUM.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> SO PRELIMINARY RESULTS SHOW
PRESIDENT EMMANUEL MACRON IN
FIRST PLACE WITH ABOUT 27% JUST
AHEAD OF FAR-RIGHT POLITICIAN
MARINE LE PEN AROUND 23%.
GIVEN WHAT WE KNOW ABOUT THE
OTHER 10 CANDIDATES AND THEIR
SUPPORTERS, PARTICULARLY
JEAN-LUC MELACHON, WHO DO YOU
THINK WILL LIKELY WIN THE
RUNOFF, MACRON OR LE PEN?
>> I THINK IT WILL BE MACRON.
AFTER ALL, THIS TIME HE WON
ALMOST TWICE AS MUCH, A LARGER
PERCENTAGE OVER LE PEN THAN HE
DID FIVE YEARS AGO IN THE FIRST
ROUND.
AND THE FIRST ROUND, AS MUCH AS
HE'S DETESTED BY MANY, MANY
FRENCH, HE WON MORE FIRST ROUND
VOTES THAN ANY CANDIDATE SINCE
FRANCOIS MITTERRAND, WHICH WAS
QUITE A LONG TIME AGO.
SO I THINK HE'S OKAY.
BUT WHAT'S HAPPENED IN FRANCE IS
PRETTY SHOCKING, BECAUSE MORE
THAN 50% OF VOTERS VOTED FOR THE
EXTREME RIGHT OR THE EXTREME
LEFT.
THAT'S A MAJORITY OF VOTERS.
AND SO I THINK THE DEBATE IN
FRANCE, WHICH HAS BEEN FAIRLY
U
UGLY DURING THIS CAMPAIGN,
SHOULD LEAD TO SOUL SEARCHING.
THE MAIN OLD PARTIES OF THE
SUPER RIGHT AND SUPER LEFT HAVE
ESSENTIALLY DISAPPEARED -- THE
CENTER RIGHT AND CENTER LEFT.
MELACHON DID VERY WELL, HE WON
ROUGHLY THE SAME VOTE FIVE YEARS
AGO, A BIT MORE THIS TIME.
THE CENTER RIGHT HAS COMPLETELY
DISAPPEARED.
MACRON HAS BECOME, TO SOME
DEGREE, THE CANDIDATE OF THE
CENTER RIGHT, BUT HE'S QUITE
UNPOPULAR.
I THINK HE'LL WIN, I THINK IT
WILL BE VERY CLOSE.
MARINE LE PEN HAS WRAPPED
HERSELF IN NICE WORDS AND HER
CATS, SHE'S BECOME A CAT
BREEDER, EVERYONE LOVES THAT,
SHE'S OFF THEENED HER IMAGE.
BUT I THINK THE FRENCH WILL
STILL HAVE A VERY HARD TIME
FORGETTING WHAT HER PARTY REALLY
STANDS FOR.
>> SO HOW CRITICAL, THEN, IS THE
LEFTIST POLITICIAN, JEAN-LUC
MELACHON, IN THIS RUNOFF AND HOW
WILL HE LIKELY URGE HIS
SUPPORTERS TO VOTE?
HE WAS JUST 1 PERCENTAGE POINT
BEHIND LE PEN.
>> MELACHON IS VERY, VERY SMART
AND VERY ARTICULATE.
HE GIVES WONDERFUL SPEECHES.
AND HE'S IN A WAY A MAN OF THE
OLD LEFT.
BUT HE HAS TAKEN OVER FROM THE
SOCIALISTS AND THE FAR-LEFT, BUT
WHAT HE'S TOLD HIS SUPPORTERS
OVERNIGHT IS, DO NOT VOTE FOR
MARIE LE PEN.
WHAT HE HASN'T SAID TO THEM,
CERTAINLY NOT YET, IS, VOTE FOR
EMMANUEL MACRON.
THE BIGGEST RISK TO MACRON IS
THAT MELAC HHON VOTERS AND THIS
51% WILL EITHER VOTE FOR LE PEN
OR STAY HOME AND ABSTAIN.
AND THAT IS MACRON'S BIGGEST
VULNERABILITY, IT SEEMS TO ME.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK FRENCH
VOTERS ARE SO POLARIZED WITH
NEARLY A QUARTER OF THE COUNTRY
SELECTING A FAR-RIGHT CANDIDATE
WHO REPRESENTS THE ABSOLUTE
OPPOSITE OF WHAT THE EU STANDS
FOR, AND WHY WAS VOTER TURNOUT
SO VERY LOW?
>> WELL, IT'S LOW IN FRENCH
TERMS.
IT'S PRETTY HIGH IN AMERICAN
TERMS, I HAVE TO SAY.
BUT I THINK PEOPLE ARE ANGRY.
AND THEY'RE TIRED.
AND THERE'S COVID.
AND THERE'S A WAR.
AND YOU HAVE IN EMMANUEL MACRON
A VERY DISTANT FIGURE.
EVERYONE KNOWS HE'S VERY, VERY
SMART.
BUT HE SEEMS DISDAINFUL OF
ORDINARY PEOPLE.
THAT'S HIS IMAGE.
HE'S SORT OF CONSIDERED A MAN OF
THE ELITE, OF THE RICH, AND AS
SOMEONE WHO CAMPAIGNED FIVE
YEARS AGO AS BEING NEITHER LEFT
NOR RIGHT, MOST FRENCH HAVE
DECIDED THAT HE IS A MAN OF THE
RIGHT.
BUT THE CENTER RIGHT.
BUT PEOPLE ARE -- I MEAN, THE
FRENCH TEND TO BE GRUMPY ANYWAY,
I HAVE TO SAY.
BUT THEY EXPRESS THEIR
GRUMPINESS IN THE FIRST ROUND IN
A VERY EXPLICIT WAY.
THE SECOND ROUND, THEY TEND TO
THINK MORE ABOUT FRANCE'S PLACE
IN THE WORLD AND HOW IMPORTANT
IT IS AND THEIR ROLE IN EUROPE
AND IN NATO.
AND I SUSPECT THAT WILL EKE THIS
VERY UNPOPULAR EMMANUEL MACRON
THROUGH TO A SECOND-ROUND
VICTORY.